au matin du 15 août 2021 les talibans
entre dans Kaboul le président
achrafrani démissionne et quitte le pays
les Mira islamiques d'Afghanistan et
rétabli les talibans sont au pouvoir 70
000 soldats aguerris et déterminés ont
réduit en poussière 20 ans d'efforts
occidentaux pour redresser l'Afghanistan
face à la déroute le monde se demande
comment ces hommes ont-ils plus vaincre
si facilement alors après un an au
pouvoir les forces talibanes se
sont-elles réellement renforcées
au niveau militaire sans conteste les
talibans sont aujourd'hui la force
dominante ils le sont depuis des années
il était d'ailleurs déjà avant la chute
officielle de Kaboul et l'instauration
d'un nouveau gouvernemental Liban
aujourd'hui l'Afghanistan compte 80 000
soldats dans ces rangs selon le chef
d'état-major de l'émirail islamique un
groupe hétéroclite composé d'hommes
formés au combat endurci par des années
de guérilla mais aussi de novices
qu'importe les talibans souhaitent
encore élargir leur troupes et atteindre
150 000 hommes soit presque 30 000 de
plus qu'un pays comme l'Espagne qui
compte pourtant le même nombre
d'habitants pour recruter il compte sur
les jeunes venus des Madras ces écoles
coraniques pakistanaises à l'origine du
mouvement taliban auquel devrait
s'ajouter d'anciens éléments des forces
afghane et un certain nombre d'hommes
issus de la population civile de futurs
camarades souvent plus motivés par
l'argent que par l'idéologie taliban
donc aujourd'hui rejoindre les forces
armées rejoindre la police c'est une
manière voilà d'espérer d'avoir un
travail pérenne mais il faut savoir que
les talibans ne sont pas toujours en
mesure de les payer donc c'est vraiment
un double tranchant les talibans
espèrent gonfler les rendre leur armée
de leur police etc mais s'ils ne sont
pas capables de payer ces gens là il on
a une grande grande partie qui feront
défections car malgré leur prise de
pouvoir les talibans ne disposent pas
encore des fonds nécessaires pour faire
pleinement fonctionner une institution
militaire
jusqu'en août 2021 80 % du budget de
l'Afghanistan était financé par des
sources extérieures un butin sur lequel
ne peuvent plus s'appuyer ta Liban alors
comment se procure-t-il de l'argent
d'abord grâce à la drogue l'Afghanistan
est le premier producteur mondial de
pavot une plante qui permet de produire
de l'opium de l'héroïne ou de la
morphine en 2021 un rapport des Nations
Unies estime que l'Afghanistan a produit
6800 tonnes d'opium lors de la saison
pour un gain estimé entre 1,8 et 2,7
milliards de dollars et même si les
miracles annoncés le 3 avril 2022
l'interdiction de la production d'opium
en Afghanistan le trafic ne devrait pas
s'arrêter pour autant les talibans
prélève aussi des taxes et surtout un
impôt islamique grâce auquel il récupère
2,5% des revenus de chaque foyer et 10%
des récoltes depuis qu'il dirige le pays
les hommes de l'émirail islamique contre
aussi plusieurs postes douaniers aux
frontières de l'Iran du Pakistan et du
Tadjikistan ils peuvent leur apporter
jusqu'à 218 millions de dollars par mois
les Talib serait aussi financé par le
Pakistan et différents donateurs privés
des pays du Golfe est-ce que ça leur
permettra de reconstruire un état de
constituer une armée nationale donc de
fonctionner comme un état je dirais un
état ordinaire non clairement en l'état
il n'en n'ont pas les moyens en janvier
2021 les talibans ont voté leur premier
budget doté de 455 millions de dollars
sa quasi totalité était destinée aux
dépenses pour faire fonctionner le
gouvernement sans que l'on sache qu'elle
part est revenu à l'armée
[Musique]
d'un point de vue logistique maintenant
de quoi dispose les talibans en plus des
vestiges de la présence soviétique dans
les années 80 et de la contrebande
d'armes ils ont surtout récupéré
énormément de matériels occidental un
certain nombre de de talibans notamment
ceux des forces armées sont habillées de
pieds en cap avec des des
uniformes américains des lunettes de
soleil des casques des forces spéciales
américaines etc etc et pour cause entre
2001 et 2020 les États-Unis étaient le
premier fournisseur d'armes du pays à
hauteur de 74% des importations suivies
par la Russie l'Italie ou encore le
Brésil
1000 mais surtout
blindés hélicoptère léger avion de
transport hélicoptère de transport
véhicules aériens armes et munitions
voici un petit au-dessus du stock de
matériel talibans selon l'Institut
international de recherche sur la paix
ces équipements restent tout de même peu
avancés même s'il pourrait poser
problème dans la région au vu de leur
quantité dans le niveau des capacités ça
leur assure une marge de manœuvre de
plusieurs années est-ce qu'ils auront
les moyens d'entretenir cette équipement
ça c'est une autre question mais en tout
cas pour l'instant
l'équipement est en assez bon état je
dirais pour leur permettre de
l'exploiter
à des fins de nuisances assez
importantes pendant plusieurs années
aucun pays n'a pour l'instant reconnu le
gouvernement mis en place par les
talibans ce qui ne veut pas forcément
dire qu'ils n'ont pas d'allier
historiquement les talibans
de par tout plein d'aspects ont des
liens très très ténus avec le Pakistan
il faut savoir que l'Iran a toujours
joué un jeu très trouble en soutenance
certains certaines factions taliban tout
le temps faisant mine de combattre
d'aliments qui constituent tout de même
voilà une menace près de leur frontières
il faut savoir aussi que les talibans
bénéficient de soutien à l'intérieur
même du pays il est assez intéressant de
voir que assez récemment enfin ces
derniers mois ils ont assez fortement
renoué avec le groupe Al-Qaïda et si on
finit par comparer l'armée afghane avec
celle de son voisin pakistanais
considéré comme la neuvième puissance
mondiale en 2022 avec 640 000 soldats
devant le Brésil ou l'Italie les
talibans ont encore de la route à faire
[Musique]